[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mitglied risiko politischer
überraschungen und alles was wichtig ist
und wird in den nächsten 20 minuten und
damit in allen einen schönen guten abend
mit mir im studio zusammen für den sport
heute abend katja stresow auch von mir
gute nacht wir blicken jetzt gemeinsam
auf die themen im überblick
kabinett komplett olaf scholz nominiert
die spd-minister riege gesundheit soll
karl lauterbach bekommen mit nancy
faeser aus hessen würde erstmals eine
frau innenministerin
[Musik]
koalitionsvertrag abgesegnet die führung
der grünen bekommt in einer urabstimmung
der parteibasis grünes licht für die
ampel
und konsequenzen aus radikalen protest
nach dem fackel aufzug vor dem
privathaus der sächsischen
gesundheitsministerin kündigt
ministerpräsident kretschmann ein hartes
vorgehen an
ein politisch spannender tag nicht nur
weil die grünen als letzte partei mit
ihrem basisvotum den weg zur neuen und
ersten ampel regierung frei gemacht
haben dazu gleich mehr wir starten die
sendung mit der spd die heute passend
zum nikolaustag ihr regierungspersonal
aus dem stiefel zauberte und da sind
durchaus überraschungen dabei der wohl
künftige kanzler scholz präsentierte
also doch karl lauterbach er wird
tatsächlich gesundheitsminister die
bisherige justizministerin christine
lambrecht soll das
verteidigungsministerium
übernehmen die vielleicht größte
überraschung nancy faeser bislang
hessische spd-chefin wird
innenministerin und erste frau an der
spitze des ministeriums auch neu klara
geywitz die einzige ostdeutsche in
dieser spd rege übernimmt das neu
geschaffene bauministerium
hubertus heil bleibt chef im
arbeitsministerium
svenja schulze bislang umweltministerin
übernimmt jetzt das ressort entwicklung
und scholz enger vertrauter wolfgang
schmidt wird chef des bundeskanzleramtes
über das spd team für die ampel
koalition jetzt britta spiekermann
da stehen sie nun die künftigen
ministerinnen und ministern großes
rätselraten in den vergangenen tagen die
spd hielt bis heute morgen geschlossen
dicht scholz hatte versprochen seine
regierung gleichberechtigt zu besetzen
das entspricht der gesellschaft in der
wir leben in der männer und frauen
jeweils die hälfte der bevölkerung
ausmachten und wo es dann auch dazu
gehören muss dass die frauen die hälfte
der macht haben allerdings so ganz geht
diese rechnung nicht auf gleichheit gibt
es nur dann wenn scholz sich selbst
nicht mitzählt karl lauterbach erfuhr
erst gestern abend dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister werden soll
nicht der wunschkandidat von scholz aber
die meisten bürgerinnen und bürger
hätten sich gewünscht dass der nächste
gesundheitsminister vom fach ist das
wirklich gut kann und dass er karl
lauterbach heißt er wird es lauter bad
ist umstritten in der eigenen partei
seine kompetenz wird aber geschätzt die
beiden müssen jetzt in der korona
politik eng zusammenarbeiten
müssen
länger dauern als viele denken wir
werden das aber schaffen impfen wird die
zentrale rolle spielen aber nicht nur wo
wir werden darüber hinaus das
gesundheitssystem stärken nancy faeser
dieser name ist weniger bekannt spd
chefin in hessen jetzt der wechsel auf
die bundesebene als erste frau soll sie
das
bundesinnenministerium übernehmen
nachfolgerin von horst seehofer werden
ein besonderes anliegen wird mir seien
die größte bedrohung die derzeit unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
habt den rechtsextremismus zu bekämpfen
klara geywitz scheiterte 2009 10 mit
scholz im kampf um den parteivorsitz
jetzt der aufstieg an die spitze des neu
geschaffenen bauministeriums die aufgabe
die vor uns liegt es riesig 400.000
wohnungen davon 100.000 gefördert zu
bauen jährlich die mieterinnen und
mieter im land brauchen sicherheit dass
sie nicht aus ihrer wohnung vertrieben
werden weil die mieten übermäßig steigen
scholz überrascht durchaus mit seiner
personalwahl und setzt gleichzeitig auf
altbekannte aus der großen koalition am
mittwoch werden die neuen im bundestag
vereidigt
und wir fragen jetzt noch bei theo koll
in berlin theo größte aufmerksamkeit im
vorfeld und größtes echo jetzt bekommt
die personalie lauterbach unbestrittener
gesundheitsexperte aber auch minister
tauglich
also kritiker vor lauter würden die
frage wahrscheinlich sehr schnell mit
nein beantworten er hat keinerlei
erfahrung ein so großes ministerium zu
führen er ist in der spd nicht besonders
gut vernetzt und gilt auch als
politischer einzelgänger der sich nicht
unbedingt soll dem kanzler beugen dürfte
wenn dann wenn er anderer meinung ist
aber erstens kann man auch ein solches
ministerium von erfahrenen
staatssekretären führen lassen und vor
allem selten waren für ein minister
fachkenntnisse so wichtig wie in dieser
pandemie und da ist der arzt und
virologe lauterbach natürlich weit vorn
und genießt im übrigen ja auch das
vertrauen eines großen teils der bürger
wir jetzt auf das komplette spd
personalpaket wie fällt da das gesamt
total aus also es ist vielleicht mit der
ausnahme von lauterbach ein absolutes
scholz team da sind viele die ihm nahe
stehen wie der arbeits und
sozialminister hubertus heil da sind
langjährige weggefährten wie der
künftige kanzleramtsminister wolfgang
schmidt oder klara geywitz mit der sich
vor zwei jahren der erfolglos um die
spd-führung beworben hatte die sonst so
wichtigen regionalen oder links rechts
kriterien die hat scholz weitgehend
ignoriert dafür gehen dass wichtige
verteidigungs und auch das
innenministerium an frauen damit hatte
die sein geschlechtergleichheit
versprechen eingelöst es gibt acht
ministerin und acht minister wobei wenn
man es ja nicht ganz genau nimmt laut
grundgesetz zählt der kanzler eigentlich
auch zum kabinett aber sehr wurde
irgendwie ausgerechnet dann vielen dank
nach berlin theo koll also es ist ein
wegweisender tag heute in berlin wer
deutschland in zukunft regieren wird wie
das kabinett der ampelkoalition aussieht
die neue bundesregierung zum
durchklicken gibt es bei zdf heute.de
zehn wochen nach der bundestagswahl
steht deutschlands erste ampel regierung
die grünen stimmten als letzte der drei
parteien für den koalitionsvertrag auch
wenn das regierungspapier nicht die
gewünschte stark grüne handschrift trägt
votierten an der basis 86 prozent mit ja
patricia wiedemeier berichtet wer wird
was wer steht wo nicht immer ganz
einfach bei den grünen doch nach einigem
hin und her hat nun auch die grüne basis
dem koalitionsvertrag zugestimmt mit
deutlicher mehrheit aber bei geringer
wahlbeteiligung
nur 57 prozent der grünen mitglieder
haben gestimmt vorausgegangen war ein
heftiger streit letzte woche zwischen
linken und reales um die ministerposten
der linke hofreiter musste am ende platz
machen für den realo beste mehr die
künftigen ministerinnen und minister sie
alle sprechen von einem echten aufwind
von einem paradigmenwechsel
aber auch von extremen herausforderungen
die versöhnung von ökologischen fragen
und ökonomischen notwendigkeiten die
anzunehmen zieht sich durch alle
ressorts 70 möglichen koalitionsvertrag
und wird neben einen aktuellen krisen
sicherlich die bewährungsprobe dieser
regierung hören wir haben sie das
ressort übergreifend vorgenommen die
zwei großen krisen unseres jahrhunderts
anzugehen nämlich zum einen das thema
klimaschutz zum anderen das thema erhalt
des artenreichtums insofern bin ich der
oberst der anwalt der bauern bei uns im
land aber gleichzeitig auch der oberste
tierschutz große herausforderungen aber
die größte seit der zeit erstmal die
bekämpfung der korona krise die ampel
startet mitten in der pandemie und muss
gleich das infektionsschutzgesetz
nachbessern deswegen wird die prioritäre
und aller aller wichtigste aufgabe
dieser neuen bundesregierung sein alles
dafür zu tun die korona pandemie in den
griff zu bekommen
die grüne basis die hat dem neuen
kabinett das vertrauen ausgesprochen
trotz des ärgers darüber dass das
verkehrsministerium an die fdp geht und
dass es kein tempolimit geben wird
ja und erste große herausforderung der
ampel wird ja sein die korona zahlen zu
drücken aktuell stabilisieren die sich
auf hohem niveau das robert koch
institut meldet 27
1836 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
desto rund 1500 weniger als vor einer
woche
81 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents steigt leicht auf 4 141,9
mitten im advent und wie im vorjahr im
grunde geht es also tatsächlich schon
wieder los mit diesen bangen fragen was
ist mit weihnachten sind große
familientreffen möglich ist es sinnvoll
welche
gelten eigentlich und betreffen die nur
ungeimpfte über den stand der diskussion
thomas garcia
weihnachtlich glänze die fußgängerzone
hannover vom heiligen fest welche
geschenke kaufen für wen das kann man
planen weniger dagegen wer darf
mitfeiern ja ich hoffe dass meine drei
kinder kommen so besuch ich weiß nicht
was bis dahin passiert ich war nur im
engsten kreis zu hause mit der familie
ich würde ungeimpfte würde ich also mit
sicherheit nicht an einer fall
beteiligen weil ich denke dass das
übertragungsrisiko zu groß ist ganz so
streng ist die aktuelle regelung nicht
sie besagt ein ungeimpfter darf maximal
zwei personen aus einem anderen haushalt
treffen das gilt aber schon für
14-jährige große weihnachtsfeste sind so
oft nicht möglich beispiel zwei
verwandte familien wollen sich treffen
plus oma und opa geht aber nur wenn alle
geimpft sind ist dass eine person nicht
dann dürfen nur zwei weitere aus einem
haushalt dabei sein aber reicht das wenn
es richtig brenzlig wird in sachen
corona man könnte nach schärfen sagt
niedersachsens landeschef und werde auch
für geimpfte dann tatsächlich darüber
reden müssen gibt es eine möglichkeit
das noch einmal zu verstärken
vor oder nach weihnachten
ob nun geltende oder nach geschäfte
regeln wer kontrolliert eigentlich ob
man sich daran hält
der weihnachtszeit polizisten oder
mitarbeiterin von ordnungsbehörden von
tür zu tür gehen und nach hinausweisen
fragen schwer vorstellbar aber wenn ein
hinweisgeber die polizei alarmiert dann
muss sie demnach gehen und wenn sie dann
mehr beteiligte als erlaubt in einer
wohnung an trifft dann drohen allen
beteiligten jeweils bußgelder bis zu
maximal 25.000 euro eine schöne
bescherung wäre das oder eben nicht und
corona zum christfest eine gabe auf die
jeder verzichten kann
trotz höchster instanzen und
schwierigsten situationen auf
intensivstationen fühlen sich viele
sachsen von den strengen corona regeln
und aufrufen provoziert immer wieder
gibt es aufmärsche ohne abstand oder
masken freitagabend zogen radikale sogar
mit fackeln vor das privathaus der
gesundheitsministerin die bundespolitik
reagierte entsetzt sachsens
regierungschef kretschmann kündigte
einen härteren kurs gegen regelbrecher
steffen moritz müller aus dresden
im sächsischen landtag wird heute die
epidemische lage festgestellt um
rechtssicher weitere corona
schutzmaßnahmen beschließen zu können
dass sich dagegen widerstand regen wird
war lange vorher im internet angekündigt
doch es blieb unerwartet ruhig
hundertschaften der polizei aus sachsen
und berlin standen ein paar dutzend
demonstranten gegenüber doch nach dem
nächtlichen fackel aufmarsch vor dem
wohnhaus der sächsischen
gesundheitsministerin war klar die
polizeipräsenz muss erhöht werden im
landtag heute viel gegenseitige
schuldzuweisung und der
ministerpräsident gibt die verantwortung
weiter
deswegen werden wir froh dankbaren die
justiz auch in diesen fällen von dem
instrument des beschleunigten verfahrens
gebrauchen nicht machen würde in einer
großen zahl so dass die strafe schnell
auf dem fuß folgt bei den
protestierenden handelt es sich
überwiegend um sympathisanten der als
rechtsextremistisch und
verfassungsfeindlich eingestuften
organisation
freies sachsen die sich über den
messenger dienst telegramm organisieren
meist an mehreren orten gleichzeitig um
der polizei das agieren so schwer wie
möglich zu machen ja das ist
organisierter widerstand so muss man das
deutlich sagen und dieser widerstand ist
darauf angelegt die demokratische
ordnung vor allen dingen auch das
monopol staatlicher
gewalt in frage zu stellen ein 80 orten
gleichzeitig haben corona gegner heute
abend kundgebungen angemeldet wie hier
in freiberg die polizei ist darauf
vorbereitet
sie dürfen gewiss sein dass die
philosophie der sächsischen polizei sich
deutlich geändert hat seit gut einer
woche und dass wir diesen corinna
gegnern auf die füße treten werden
auf dieser montagabend wird wieder eine
herausforderung für die polizei werden
und in freiberg bei der angekündigten
demo gegen kroner maßnahmen ist thomas
bärsch thomas die landesregierung
kündigt bei unzulässigen demos
entschlossenes handeln an vor ort sieht
es dann aber oft anders aus wie passt
das denn zusammen
ja wir sind hier in freiberg die lage
stellt sich hier absolut unübersichtlich
da ich komme gleich dazu das problem für
die polizei ist tatsächlich dass die
sogenannten freien sachsen auf über 80
demonstrationen in ganz sachsen
hinweisen die erfahrung zeigt dass diese
demonstrationen oder die spaziergänger
auch nicht alle stattfinden müssen am
letzten montag haben 50 von diesen
veranstaltungen auch eben nicht
stattgefunden für die polizei ist das
aber egal diesen 80 potenzielle
brandherde die man im auge behalten muss
um dann zu sehen ob sich hier oder da
irgendwas aufschaukelt dazu kommt wenn
die polizei irgendwo hinschaut dann
trifft sie auf geprüfte demonstranten
die sich als spaziergänger ausgeben die
zum beispiel auch keine plakate und
dergleichen haben und deswegen muss die
polizei hier mit großem
fingerspitzengefühl entscheiden haben
wir hier spaziergänger haben wir hier
demonstranten sind die mindestabstände
eingehalten und dergleichen mehr da ist
hier wirklich nicht darum zu beneiden
hier in freiberg hören wir dass der zug
von ungefähr 300 demonstranten derzeit
am weiterlaufen gehindert wurde da wird
man sehen wie sich das entwickelt
dankeschön nach freiberg thomas bärsch
die pandemie hat weltweit zu massiven
einbrüchen in der wirtschaft geführt
nicht jedoch in der rüstungsindustrie
die 100 größten waffenschmieden haben
ihre umsätze 2020 sogar noch gesteigert
zusammen setzten sie rund 470 milliarden
euro um teilt das forschungsinstitut sie
prix mit das sind 1,3 prozent mehr als
2009 10 spitzenreiter bleiben die usa
die vier deutschen rüstungsunternehmen
auf der liste verbuchten im vergangenen
jahr 7,9 milliarden euro
in myanmar zerschlägt sich immer mehr
die hoffnung auf demokratie jetzt wurde
die frieden
nobelpreisträgerin mit pardon sanssouci
zu zwei jahren haft verurteilt unter
anderem wegen angeblicher anstiftung zum
aufruhr
eigentlich hatte ihre partei im januar
freie wahlen mit abstand gewonnen zum
zweiten mal in folge im februar aber
putschte sich das militär an die macht
der protest auf den straßen wurde blutig
niedergeschlagen und sushi festgenommen
ihre verurteilung jetzt durch ein
sondergericht halten viele beobachter
für eine fast peter kunz sie wissen was
sie riskieren die wenigen die nach dem
urteil den wir heute wagten auf die
straße zu gehen sie wissen dass das
regime kein pardon kennt seit es mit
einem putsch im februar die macht in
myanmar übernommen hat die generäle
haben der demokratie den krieg erklärt
und ihr die in lima für die freiheit
steht sun tzu chi
friedensnobelpreisträgerin und lebende
legende
2010 kam sie nach 15 jahren hausarrest
frei zweimal gewann sie wahlen haushoch
die runterziehen vergangenheit bis die
generäle den kurz wahr gewordenen traum
wieder beendeten sotschi und der
präsidenten jan maas mit dem sie die
regierung führte wurden vor ein
militärgericht gestellt
abgeschottet von jeder öffentlichkeit
zwei jahre haft nur ein erstes urteil
gegen die 76-jährige weitere prozesse
gegen sie sind angekündigt es ist ganz
klar dass das militär hier zeigt wie
bereitet man es gegen oppositionelle
vorzugehen und wie sehr man kritische
stimmen zum schweigen bringen möchte wir
befürchten dass es tausenden menschen
die weniger prominenz und als auch in
sanssouci jetzt eben ähnlich gehen
könnte wie us militär hat sich die
herrschaft zurückgeholt unterdrückt
minderheiten oder vertreibt sie wie die
muslimischen ohnehin ja vor dem
internationalen gerichtshof hatte in
sanssouci die streitkräfte ihres landes
noch gegen völkermord vorwürfe in schutz
genommen jetzt ist sie selbst wieder
schutzlos ausgeliefert
viele sagen das war ein krasses letztes
formel 1 rennen und damit geht es jetzt
im sport und mit der katastrophe weiter
wer sich die zweieinhalb stunden zeit
genommen hat wurde belohnt denn das
premiere rennen in jeddah in saudi
arabien war an spannung kaum zu
überbieten zahlreiche unfälle rennen
unterbrechungen und als krönung das wo
ich hitziges duell der letzten jahre
zwischen max verstappen und dem sieger
des tages hätten
die nerven lagen blank in seinem
mercedes stand als hamilton von
verstappen im red bull regelwidrig
ausgekontert wurde der weltmeister
rechts war schon vorbeigezogen da fuhr
der niederländer eine abkürzung das
erbitterte duell wurde aber wenig später
von der rennleitung korrigiert
verstappen musste den briten wieder
vorbeilassen sein abruptes abbremsen
wiederum führte zu einer kollision weil
hamilton überrascht war mit lädierter
freund schaffte es der brite doch noch
am niederländer vorbei der hielt zudem
eine zehn sekunden zeitstrafe hamiltons
sieg in jeddah vor verstappen bedeutet
punktgleichheit im schon verloren
geglaubten titel kampf erstmals in der
formel-1-geschichte gibt es einen
ultimativen showdown nächste woche beim
letzten rennen in abu dhabi
zurück nach deutschland in die
fußball-bundesliga in der borussia
mönchengladbach ein debakel erlebt hat
null zu 6 verloren die gladbacher zu
hause gegen den sc freiburg der letzte
also der sechste treffer fiel bereits in
der 37 spielminute gladbach am boden und
die freiburger euphorisiert und auch
sprachlos und auch weiter auf platz vier
der tabelle
ja diese sechs tore und die anderen 35
dieses aktuellen spieltag können sie
sich bei uns noch einmal anschauen alle
partien finden sie ausführlich
zusammengefasst bei zdf heute.de und in
der zdf- heute- app und noch diese
erfolgsgeschichte aus den usa wo dem
deutschen american footballer amon
rasant braun großartiges gelungen ist im
spiel seiner detroit lions gegen die
minnesota vikings glänzte der 22-jährige
mit athletik und selbstbewusstsein dann
fing er mit ablauf der uhr den bei
touchdown letzte sein erster überhaupt
und das in letzter sekunde und dieser
sieg der lions ist der erste seit einem
jahr freut sich auch der nikolaus und
die anderen sowieso passiert nicht alle
tage
dankeschön katja und wir sagen bitte
aufpassen wenn sie unterwegs sind denn
in der nacht brot von westen glätte
durch schnee und schneeregen mehr
erklärt gleich katja oliver marietta
slomka begrüßt sie später um 21 uhr 45
zum heute journal und wir sehen uns
morgen um 7 wieder schön dass sie dabei
waren ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
entspannten abend
[Musik]
entdecken sie wie sie ihren diabetes mit
farben einfach im griff haben dass
mundart ultra plus reflex zeigt an ob
sie unterhalb innerhalb oder oberhalb
ihres bereiches liegen es lobt sie und
bietet personalisierte empfehlungen
verbunden mit ihrer gesundheit und ihrem
smartphone buttert
[Musik]
gutscheincodes demnächst ein lächeln
entlockte einzig sein neues plettenberg
das rockte
bist du ein wunder wirken ist unser
fakt ist es gibt sein palette an arm
tragen 39 euro monatsrate überlegt noch
starten
jeden monat erinnerungen voller freude
ihre fotos als ganz persönliches
geschenk
mit einem fotokalender von cewe
mein name ist ich habe mein leben einem
thema gebieten den bakterien in unserem
körper gemeinsam mit führenden
wissenschaftler haben wir das geheimnis
dieser bakterien entschluss so entstand
ungünstig heute die nummer eins in
deutschlands apotheker fragen sie nach
antibiotika es erneut mit b-vitaminen
weil wir oft genug das richtige nerven
futter brauchen
[Musik]
bei halskratzen helfen natürlich viel
lieber ruhe und geborgenheit und natur
alles als praktisches rachen spray gegen
halskratzen mit exotisch und honig
naturalis natürlich für dich da
das winterwetter im zdf wird ihnen
präsentiert von feinkost käfer
[Musik]
guten abend tief garrett bringt uns
schon heute nacht schnee und regenfälle
aber dieses wolkenband zerfleddert
morgen über tag mehr und mehr dann
lassen schnee und regen auch ganz bald
nach und wir sehen wieder häufiger die
sonne aber jetzt in der nacht wird es
gefährlich glatt von westen her und bis
zum frühen morgen erreicht dieses schnee
und regen band etwa eine linie hamburg
münchen gefährlich glatt auf den straßen
kann es aber wieder eigentlich überall
sein bei tiefsttemperaturen zwischen
plus 3 und minus vier grad über schnee
am alpenrand geht sogar bis minus neun
grad runter und morgen bleibt es zum
teil beim dauerfrost jedenfalls hier
nordosten da steigen die werte nicht
über minus 1 grad hinaus im westen ist
es deutlich milder besonders am
oberrhein da klettere die werte bis 7
grad und auch morgen vormittag kann es
noch einige schnee regen und schneefälle
geben zwischen schleswig holstein und
dem alpenrand am längsten schneidet es
wohl noch in bayern dann kommt aber doch
auch häufiger die sonne zum vorschein
zum beispiel in sachsen aber auch im
westen am mittwoch müssen uns dann
wieder auf sehr gefährliche
straßenverhältnisse einstellen mit
schnee und schneeregen besonders in
baden-württemberg und bayern das reicht
etwa bis zum thüringer wald und
winterlich geht es dann auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter schön ab